beautiful clouds across the sky this
morning what a gorgeous Sunrise we're
going to we're going to keep these
clouds really coming all day long for
your Friday I don't need the umbrella
today but do plan on some rain coming in
for the weekend lots of 40s around East
Side has some 30s and we've got 36 out
at Red Rock cooler 20's up there in
Lincoln County and we could get some
fairly low snow levels by the time we
get to Monday and Tuesday we've got a
couple of waves coming in I don't think
that we're going to get a whole lot from
this first system temperatures right now
in the mid 30s Pahrump 44 in Boulder
City 54 in Laughlin that first wave will
be moving into California and eventually
into our area for Saturday afternoon and
Saturday night we're looking at rain on
the future cast and Mountain snow snow
levels should be up around 6 down to
about 6 000 feet but then Monday into
Tuesday comes the second wave and I
think it's going to have colder air with
it which will lower the snow levels we
already have winter storm warnings that
have been issued now 4 for the weekend
and likely will be reissued again for
Monday Tuesday but let's concentrate on
Saturday noon all the way until Sunday 4
a.m We may see another 6 to 10 inches of
snow in our local mountains and if we
don't get that much this weekend I think
we might make up for it Monday Tuesday
45 for the mountain today with Cloudy
Skies Lee Canyon in the low 40s and
again count on weekend snow Saturday
afternoon into Saturday night in part of
Sunday and then I think we'll get a
break Sunday afternoon before Monday the
rain and snow returns 59 for your Friday
again so Saturday afternoon showers and
Mountain snow into Saturday night could
linger into early Sunday morning and
then I think we'll have at least partly
cloudy skies if not more sunshine on
Sunday and then that second wave moves
through early Monday through Monday
night into Tuesday with Breezy to Gusty
winds and that's going to help cool
things off too next week to the low 50s
mornings back to the 30s